joining us now congressman louie gohmert
he serves in the House Judiciary
Committee he was another of a fiery
presence all day long watch
we started this impeachment proceeding
about the Russia hoax and the Russia
collusion and demanding all these
documents about the Russia collusion and
it kept changing and then it went to
bribery and extortion and emoluments and
all these other things never in history
has a president been accused of crimes
with with the target constantly changing
this is outrageous and it needs to come
to an end so there settled on abuse of
power and obstruction of Congress and
we'll see if we get a vote in committee
tonight stepping out to help us out and
explain what's going on from the inside
out congressman Louie Gohmert
congressman Goldberg how would you
describe what's been going on for the
last two days it's an animal farm it's
insane it's just so outrageous i mean
i've set i've set through some really
bad trials as a judge but this exceeds
anything i've ever had to sit through it
is such an outrage and you know it's so
ironic too you know they don't have a
crime they've had to drop every single
crime that they've allege they've got
nothing now other than they basically
have offended the majority in congress
they've abused power they he is abuse
power but like turley said it's a
congress that's abusing power but how
ironic that today that joe biden would
say if he were subpoenaed to the
congress of the senate he would defy it
he wouldn't do it well that's what this
mob is trying to kick out Trump from the
White House and we just took up an
amendment that Jim Jordan had filed they
would said okay you know basically you
say you it was an unfair election in
2016 let's amend your impeachment
articles to say you're not trying to
keep him from
running again our being elected again oh
no they don't want to they don't want to
eliminate that that's the one that we've
just taken up and it pretty clear
they've been exposed but can I point out
one silver lining here you know because
I try to find some silver lining no
matter how bad it's been we've known
that this was a swamp we've known that
there were swamp creatures one of the
biggest problems here in Washington is
figuring out who's part of the deep
State who are the swamp creatures and
Trump derangement syndrome is so bad
it's kind of like when when sergeant
York gobbled like a turkey in World War
one and the Germans jerked their head up
these guys have been raising their heads
so we could see who needs to be fired
who needs to be out of this world but
Congress may founder spent a lot of
people who weren't watching network
television in the 70s and don't remember
1998 when Bill Clinton admit he lied
under oath and admitted he had an affair
with an intern and this is different
this president says there's nothing here
and that's where the disagreement is but
you have a lot of moderate Democrats
that are not on board with this
you have congressmen gotten heimer says
I've made up my mind Susan Wilder I've
made up my mind
Anthony princey I've made up my wife
Colin Peterson Alisa slotnick van jeff
van drew max Rose Tom Suozzi there's a
lot of Democrats who are not on board
with this we've never seen anything like
this no I've never seen anything like it
I've heard about witch hunts I've heard
about lynch mobs but I've never seen
something like this using the
congressional system to try to destroy
people that have committed no crimes
whatsoever it's just is it's incredible
to be a part of watching and knowing
that we can't win these votes because
the majority of majest almost unbearable
233 - 197 they have an advantage and
they need 217 to impeach nobody wants to
get impeached but poll wise they seem to
be losing on this lastly congressman
what are we going to see tonight a vote
in the committee to impeach and then it
goes to the gym to the floor win yet
there we don't know for sure but at some
point
we're trying to clean this mess up and
and they are at some point going to pull
a question and then we'll have to vote
on the question they and I majority
they'll in debate and then they will
vote and you know how they're going to
vote they've all indicated you know what
17 out of 16 or 17 voted already last
summer two impeaching and that was back
when they were saying it was all about
the Russian pollution so they were ready
to to impeach him and that hasn't
changed
never mind the facts gotcha congressman
bad news you got to go back in thanks
for joining us though audience
appreciates the inside story as we just
go on and on